the iphone 14 is gonna be better than a
lot of the people think it's gonna be at
least according to the current sentiment
that's going around with a lot of
different reports saying that the lower
end models of this year's iphone 14
lineup are going to be very
disappointing with very little changes
compared to the iphone 13. for example
we're not expecting any big changes in
the camera department other than an
upgrade to the selfie camera but on the
pro models they're going to be getting a
brand new 48 megapixel main camera that
supports 8k video recording at 60fps on
top of that the pro models will likely
be getting an always on display mode and
a new dual hole punch selfie camera
design compared to the current notch
design that's going to the regular
models and going even further it looks
like only the pro models will be getting
the a16 chip this year with the regular
iphone 14 and 14 max models sticking
with the previous a15 chip that we
already have in the current iphone 13.
and we just got a new report from the
elec which mentions that the new pro
models will be getting higher quality
m12 graded materials for the display
panels compared to the regular iphone 14
models which will have lower m11
standards which is a move to help apple
cut costs so because of those reasons
and a few others a lot of people are
expecting the regular iphone 14s to be a
crappy and disappointing upgrade but in
this video i'm gonna talk about some
reasons why i think the regular iphone
14 models will actually be pretty solid
in terms of upgrades compared to the
iphone 13 lineup including shrimp apple
pro saying that there will be a
performance improvement even despite
sticking with the same a15 chip but
before i get into those brand new leaks
i want to discuss the whole a15 versus a
16 chip ordeal and why i think it's not
going to be that big of an issue this
time around according to shrimp apple
pro who has proven himself to be pretty
reliable in terms of leaks like breaking
the iphone 14 pro dual hole punch design
way back in july of last year and he has
also said back in may that the a16
bionic chip coming this year will
continue to use this same five nanometer
tsmc n5p process node that the a15 chip
is based on right now yes the exact same
process now a lot of people will
probably be asking how could that
possibly make any sense at all because
the android phones that we have right
now especially last year's snapdragon 8
gen 1 it's built on the samsung 4
nanometer process as well as the tsmc 4
nanometer process which is basically n4p
so why would apple stick to 5 nanometer
with n5p
well first of all it seems like 4
nanometer didn't really make much of a
difference in the first place because if
you look at the benchmarks or the tests
from geekerwan on the snapdragon 8gen 1
they basically called it a piece of crap
with the cherry on top because if you
look at this you have the snapdragon 88
right here that's the old version and if
you look at the score per watt it beaded
out
basically in single core and multi-core
with better score per watt so it was
actually a downgrade in terms of the
efficiency so it seems like the whole
four nanometer thing was just a
marketing stunt or basically trying to
sell it however the new snapdragon 8 gen
1 plus is finally seeing some decent
efficiency gains with some really
impressive efficiency this time around
and that seems like it's because they
are now fine tuning the design and
properly optimizing it so with that said
what if apple could get the same amount
of gains just with a new design and more
optimizations on the same n5p 5
nanometer process now as for another
reason why apple chose to stick with n5p
what if apple planned to make the a16
chip on three nanometer but it was
delayed
so that could have been a cause but
honestly i do not think it's a big deal
that they're sticking to n5p and that's
mainly because of the overheating
problems that the iphone has had for a
couple of years ago when it was very
very bad on the iphone 12 lineup when
they introduced 5g and it did get better
with the iphone 13 series but the issue
is still hanging around so basically the
chip doesn't have a good way of cooling
itself down with it just having the most
basic form of passive cooling and we
even showed you guys that in terms of
performance per gpu core the new 4 core
version of the a15 chip isn't much
different than the four core version of
the previous a14 for example the ipad
air 4 with the a14 chip scores 10.6
higher than the iphone 13 with the new
a15 chip in terms of geekbench 5 metal
graphics performance so the point that
i'm trying to make is that with the new
a16 chip apple can raise the clock speed
that the chip runs at to make it faster
but the problem with that is that the
current a15 chip is already vastly
limited because of the overheating
issues so making the a16 chip faster
isn't going to do much at all for the
performance however if apple were to
dramatically improve the passive cooling
system itself it would essentially
unlock a lot of lost performance that
they were missing out on because of the
excessive overheating and that's not
even a joke just by fixing the passive
cooling problems even the old a14 chip
within the new iphone 14 would instantly
outperform the a15 chip within the
iphone 13. and luckily we've been
hearing some rumors from the well-known
apple analyst meets jaquo that apple is
aggressively testing new vapor chamber
thermal systems for use in the iphone
suggesting that the technology will make
its way to the flagship iphone in the
near future and to add further evidence
for why it should be ready shrimp apple
pro mentioned that this year's iphone 14
lineup should come with a new internal
design which basically means a
redesigned logic board compared to the
iphone 13 lineup so why not add in a
vapor chamber cooler right now while
they're at it and that basically makes
apple's job a lot easier with this
year's iphones because they can easily
reuse the same old n5p process node from
tsmc without having to make major
changes to the a16 chip and still get a
really nice performance boost simply
because of the new cooling system
allowing apple to unlock that lost
performance from overheating so because
of that i think shrimp apple pro is
totally right about apple reusing n5p
again because it's going to be the
cheapest possible solution for apple
which is important in these inflationary
times and the end consumer won't know
any better because the a16 ship will in
fact be faster than before and miles
ahead of the competition and not only
that but consumer satisfaction will go
up with the new iphone 14 lineup because
we likely won't have to deal with those
display dimming issues anymore at least
nowhere near as bad as it currently is
and then next year with the a17 chip
they can finally move on to tsmc's three
nanometer process node which will be a
lot more efficient and then as far as
the regular iphone 14 model sticking to
the same a15 chip while the pro models
get the a16 well shrimp apple pro
believes that despite sticking to the
same ship the regular non-pro models
will still have an overall performance
boost over the iphone 13 series and that
totally makes sense especially if apple
is going to be upgrading the cooling
system which will instantly give it a
performance boost with the same exact
chip and on top of that rumors are
pointing to the entire iphone 14 lineup
coming with six gigs of ram this time
around compared to the regular iphone 13
models that come with only four
gigabytes right now so that by itself is
going to be a nice upgrade for people
who choose to stick with the regular
iphone 14 models so for all those
reasons that i mentioned i honestly
think that the iphone 14 is still going
to be a pretty good upgrade and it's
going to be quite a bit better than the
iphone 13 models that we have right now
even despite sticking with the a15 chip
and not getting some of the other pro
features i think it's still going to be
a nice worthy upgrade now if you totally
disagree with me let me know in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
this video and learn something new click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]